precisamente este fin de semana en su
visita a oval de la gente de la
comunidad anual de le decía el
presidente que por favor hiciera algo yo
bailén le respondió tranquilos voy a
hacer algo ese hacer algo es
precisamente eso hablar con los
republicanos y los demócratas en el
senado para poder avanzar con la
legislación para restringir el porte de
armas y la compra y venta de armas en
eeuu sin embargo esto parece un disco
rayado disco rayado porque cada vez que
ocurre este tipo de tiroteos en eeuu los
demos los republicanos y los demócratas
hablan al respecto y dicen que van a
hacer algo pero al final la la mitad de
los republicanos en el senado
muchos de ellos financiados precisamente
por las armas por las compañías de armas
en eeuu terminan bloqueando las
iniciativas para restringir el porte de
armas sin embargo hoy pues el presidente
dijo que el presidente yo bailén dijo
que la segunda enmienda no es absoluta
es decir que la enmienda que le permite
a los estadounidenses el porte de armas
no está completa y que este tipo de
eventos termina generando más conciencia
y por ende presionando el cambio sin
embargo terminó reconociendo
por orden ejecutiva no puede simplemente
prohibir las armas en eeuu o restringir
los permisos de salvoconducto difícil
ponerlos de acuerdo cristóbal dejemos de
lado esta coyuntura y hablemos de esa
fecha importante que conmemora hoy eeuu
también a raíz de estas declaraciones es
un día muy importante el 'memorial day'
que significa entonces esta fecha para
la sociedad de ese país y para la
historia estadounidense
es uno de los pocos festivos que tiene
eeuu que tienen los ciudadanos en eeuu y
conmemora a los soldados los soldados
que lucharon para las fuerzas públicas
estadounidenses desde la guerra civil es
también en sede donde ganan los estados
del norte versus los estados
confederados hay eventos en todas las
ciudades de el país acá en washington
hay google desfile famoso en la avenida
constitución hay un concierto en el moll
nacional y también una conmemoración en
los monumentos de los soldados caídos
también en el moll nacional pero además
es de alguna manera el inicio de el
verano abren las piscinas públicas abren
muchos sitios públicos dedicados al
verano y la gente obviamente sale en las
calles a celebrar este inicio de verano
y este festivo en eeuu